by now Bob is spending most of his days
on-site
his philosophy is that if you invest in
the craftsmanship now it'll pay off
later one of the other thing that will
define this resort from a lot of the
other casinos is this depth of design
this depth of feeling and atmosphere so
you'll be able to come and literally
spend two or three days
god forbid not gambling just looking at
the at the beauty of it looking and
taking it all in
while Bob looks at the buildings his
assistant Paul Duggan looks at the sky
and he's not happy the clouds fantastic
job but under our finished light
conditions we can see all of this three
dimensionality coming out from the
previous trade contractor who installed
the board and again to contract he was
meant to perform a level five finish
which means it must be flat
a bumpy sky doesn't cut the mustard even
if sprinkler caps are a necessary
compromise and the biggest guy in the
casino version of st. Mark's Square has
to be completely redone optimistically
about a twenty day program it's an
expensive undertaking but worth it to
ensure the illusion remains in place and
the visitors are awed by its magic
in the pursuit of perfection sometimes
all the glitters really is gold just in
the ceiling a line in this casino
there's three million faces of gold leaf
we have about 60 people here at the
present they do nothing else all day
that pattern gold leaf the Wow space the
central atrium of the casino is filled
with scaffolding it's a moment of truth
the murals are being installed
they've been digitally reproduced from
the originals rather than using real
painters to paint copies
Italian experts have been called in to
supervise the melting they will place
70,000 square feet of carefully
reproduced paintings the casino is
quickly taking shape and a final date is
set for the opening August 28 which
signifies easy money in Chinese it's
always good to be on the right side of
fate
outside the taps go on for the lagoon a
total of 6.2 million gallons of water
are needed to fill it and to bring the
venetie to life
the casino floor is also awakening the
switch has been thrown and for the most
part the electronics work it seems that
dick won his battle against the rats
with a few minor repairs the
installations can begin
finally everything is coming together